wait wait actually that's a really good
idea Kelly what did I say I talk a lot
so I've learned to just tune myself out
do I need to be liked absolutely not I
like to be liked I enjoy being liked
I have to be liked
but it's not like this compulsive need
to be liked like my need to be praised I
don't want to work I just want to bang
on this muggle did you ask me here for
any specific reason I am dead inside
would I rather be feared or loved
um easy both
I want people to be afraid of how much
they love me
you're Ali Larter I'm Beyonce I Am
Beyonce always I am about to do
something very bold this job that I've
never done before
try
it's true around this office in the past
I have been a little abrupt with people
but the doctor said if I can't find a
new way to relate more positively to my
surroundings I'm going to die
I'm more to die I just want to lie on
the beach and eat hot dogs
that's all I've ever wanted
and I knew exactly what to do but in a
much more real sense I had no idea what
to do I
oh I guess I'm a loser
[Music]
I don't hate it I just don't like it at
all and it's terrible
I wonder what people like about me
probably my jugs
I work hard all day I like knowing that
there's going to be a break most days I
just sit and wait for the break what is
the most inspiring thing I ever said to
you
don't be an idiot changed my life
whenever I'm about to do something I
think would an idiot do that and if they
would I do not do that thing
I take an extra shot of insulin in
preparation for this cake today if I
don't have some kids soon I might uh why
don't you just have an apple why don't
you mind your business I get 10 vacation
days a year and I try to hold off taking
them for as long as possible and this
year I got to the third week in January
yes I have a dream and it's not some MLK
dream for equality
I want to own a decommissioned
lighthouse
and I want to live at the top
and nobody knows I live there
and there's a button that I can press
and launch that Lighthouse into space
my resolution was to get more attention
I have been trying to get on jury duty
every single year since I was 18 years
old
to get to go sit in an air-conditioned
room downtown judging people while my
lunch was paid for
that is the life
ultimatums are key basically nobody does
anything for me anymore unless I
threaten to kill myself
are you trying to hurt my feelings
because if so you are succeeding
fortunately my feelings regenerated
twice the speed of a normal Lance it's
like I used to tell my wife
I do not apologize unless I think I'm
wrong and if you don't like it you can
leave well I manage my department and
I've been doing that for several years
now
a lot of life lessons along the way
your Department's just you right yes Jim
Ben I am not easy to manage a great
opportunity squandered absolutely a
crushing blow
yes
will I get over it
[Music]
um
no
but Life Goes On
not for me
I do not like pregnant women in my
workspace they're always complaining
they have varicose veins too I have
swollen ankles I'm constantly hungry and
you think my nipples don't get sore too
do you think I don't need to know the
fastest way to the hospital it's weird
I'd rather she be alone
than with somebody
is that love
sometimes I feel like everyone I work
with is an idiot
and by sometimes I mean all times
all the time
every of the time
I love inside jokes
love to be a part of on Sunday
how can I get you to stay money yeah
yeah we all want money
but there is none on the budget so
tell me why you're really leaving money
I can't control what I say to people I
spend the whole day talking I love
catching people in the ACT that's why I
always whip open doors I was in my
mid-20s and
I was going through a lot of stuff
I think I never really processed 911
because I do deserve a vacation
sometimes Batman's got to take off his
cape I don't back down my sister and I
used to be best friends and we haven't
talked in 16 years over some
disagreement I don't even remember
so
yeah
I'm pretty good
so I received my first Valentine from a
secret admirer
roses are red violets are blue it's time
for your dental cleaning and maybe a
checkup too
many people on this Earth I need a new
plague